[Musique]
les sénateurs
agissent accès aux soins le Sénat
enrichit la proposition de loi jeudi 7
décembre députés et sénateurs sont
parvenus à un accord en commission mixte
paritaire sur la proposition de loi
relative à l'accès aux soins par
l'engagement territorial des
professionnels ce texte vise à modifier
l'organisation territoriale de l'offre
de soins et comporte également des
mesures relatives aux études de santé et
à
l'hôpital le compromis entre les deux
chambres préserve les principaux apports
du Sénat avec notamment le renforcement
du rôle du médecin coordonnateur en épad
et la création du statut d'infirmier
référent dont le rôle dans le suivi du
patient sera mieux reconnu surtout
sénateurs et députés ont confirmé la
suppression des articles 3 et 4 bis
prévoyant l'adhésion automatique des
professionnels aux communautés
professionnelles territoriales de santé
et révisant le régime applicable à la
permanence des soins
ambulatoires le Sénat avait rejeté ses
dispositions juridiquement fragiles et
très mal reçu par les professionnells de
santé concernant l'hôpital le texte issu
de la commission mixte paritaire
préserve la rédaction du Sénat
permettant non seulement d'engager un
rééquilibrage de la permanence des soins
en établissement de santé entre hôpitaux
publics et établissements privés mais
aussi de renforcer la gouvernance
médico-administrative ainsi modifié ce
texte contribuera à répondre aux
attentes de nos concitoyens en matière
d'accès aux soins sans crisper
inutilement les professionnels de santé
investis au quotidien au service de
notre système de santé et lasser des
signaux contreproductifs qui sont
parfois envoyés le texte de compromis
sera examiné par le Sénat en séance
publique lundi 18
décembre pour en savoir plus consultez
le site Internet du
Sénat